okay so Sarah Huckabee Sanders is
leaving the Trump administration as
press secretary and we talked late last
year about reports that she was going to
be leaving her position as a completely
dishonest and disgusting press secretary
at the end of 2018 that didn't happen it
took a little longer but she is leaving
at the end of this month and she is
going to be leaving the White House and
the Trump administration in a state of
total of dishonesty and embarrassment
for the relationship that the Trump
administration has had to the press
corps remember that she has not actually
done a press briefing for just under a
hundred days I don't remember the exact
number but it's the first half of I
think March that she did her last press
briefing so in a sense it's a perfect
time to leave because she's basically
been missing as press secretary for a
long time this announced of course by
presidential tweet Donald Trump putting
the most positive possible spin on it
saying quote after three and a half
years our wonderful Sarah Huckabee
Sanders will be leaving the White House
at the end of the month and going home
to the great state of Arkansas she is a
very special person with extraordinary
talents who has done an incredible job I
hope she decides to run for governor of
Arkansas she would be fantastic Sarah
thank you for a job well done I actually
can't think of any extraordinary talent
that Sarah Huckabee Sanders possesses
other than the ability and I guess it is
a sort of talent most people would would
cringe at doing it she does have the
extraordinary talent of being able to
tell absolutely disgusting provable lies
with no visible shame or embarrassment
on her facial expression and in the
context of the Trump administration and
defending what she's had to defend for
these three and a half years I guess
that does take something akin to talent
or skill and again on the merits
hilariously it barely matters that she's
leaving because as far as the press
briefings are concerned there hasn't
been one in nearly 100 days and it's
really really important that Sarah
Huckabee Sanders actions and her role in
the propaganda machine of the Trump
administration
not be sanitized in retrospect I we've
talked about how we've got to be careful
when we talk about ways in which George
W Bush was not as bad as Donald Trump in
terms of his diplomatic skills
relationships to allies whatever we
don't want to be incorrectly looking
back at Bush with rose-colored glasses
because he was a horrible war monger who
supervised absolutely terrible economic
circumstances and boneheaded military
decision after military decision but in
some ways he wasn't as bad as Trump in
the same way you know Sean Spicer was
terrible truly but Sarah Huckabee
Sanders was much worse and we can't
allow her image to be retroactive
retrospectively rather sanitized she
concocted not just political lies but
just straight-up obvious lies like when
she said that when Donald Trump fired
James Comey in May of 2017 that a bunch
of people from the FBI had reached out
to her and said they liked that the
president fired James Comey that was a
complete and total lie she admitted that
that was a complete and total lie under
oath when she was interviewed by Robert
Moeller's investigation so this is
concocting a false story whole cloth not
a slip of the tongue as she called it
and I could sit here and just list a
bunch of these demonstrably false lies
that she's concocted many of you already
know them the point is she needs to be
remembered for shameless lying and Paul
Waldman wrote in The Washington Post
over the weekend about this and he said
quote in a more just world Sanders would
be shamed and shunned forever she
wouldn't be able to get a job her
neighbors would avoid her she would be
regarded with the universal contempt she
has so richly earned it's not the world
we live in
she'll be welcomed back in Arkansas as
some kind of hero she will be a top
prospect for all sorts of big companies
with nice salaries and Trump actually I
don't know if he's joking by saying she
could be governor of Arkansas she
probably will have a good shot at being
the governor of Arkansas at some point
in time her track record of lies and
deception have almost qualified her for
future riches and prominent prestigious
positions and that's a bigger problem
than her
that's a bigger problem than Trump it's
a far bigger problem but when we talk
about a degenerate sycophant we're
really talking about someone exactly
like Sarah Huckabee Sanders that's who
comes to mind to me let me know what you
think about her departure and the timing
of it I'm on Twitter at D Pakman the
show is on Twitter at David Pakman show
it is a very very good show today if you
love learning new things you probably
want to check this out the david pakman
show today is sponsored by Skillshare
and we're giving you two entire months
of free access to Skillshare when you
click the link underneath this video
Skillshare is a vibrant online learning
community offering more than 25,000
video classes on just about anything you
can think of get better at playing an
instrument learn to use Photoshop how to
edit videos they have classes on drawing
painting business cooking nutrition
personal productivity and I'm not even
really scratching the surface I recently
took a great class on introductory
watercolour painting I'm still not good
but I am learning and you can access the
entire library of fun easy-to-use online
courses for free for two months by using
the link underneath this video two
months of learning something that's
totally new to you something you want to
get better at something you already love
or you can get ahead in your career by
learning new skills that will help you
at your job I've gotten a ton out of it
Pat has taken some courses that he's
found really valuable and I think you'll
love it to get started for free by
clicking the link under this video